we had nothing that was just some damn
land you got something that didn't open
you just make it beautiful and that's
what they did
I think the father the way I am from any
of the realities just seven minutes para
and unlike that I just like the area
just nice to have the family around
because we right here so that's like the
best thing pull me everybody no far than
18-hundred is known for its railroad
cars you look like a rag Li neighborhood
to me it was hard to get a job in full
of a lot of times that me being a single
parent is hard some mothers always be
away from their kids I used to spend
like two hours just traveling trying to
get some jobs but now I got a job right
in my own neighborhood which is great
have anyone been to the factory with all
the pretty colors of the buildings down
in Harlan it's not your normal warehouse
I'm the one that's responsible for from
this fine print on miles of Memphis
company is about being yourself I had a
phone while you at work
hey Tommy Memphis maybe how almost three
years now
but never come true this location was
like a blessing to everybody I come in
with no skills and they taught me
everything that I need to know hey Jimmy
we really come in and help this
community you know we bring people there
from this area code giving them a job so
we're going to teach them like we're not
going to just say you're not good enough
it's a messy job but I find it get it
clean I'll come in starting off as
packing bottles to run into some
Lowe's is running great perfect but it
sometimes where are we missing a line
here where the barco is there and that's
when I got to get in with my tools
working in that machine got me feeling
handy now for like superwoman all I need
is my cage that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody say you have kids that young
age did some statistic but they became
like my biggest motivation it's just
bigger than just all we make it so boy
just got a job they know that mom
working for us a lot of people they
don't see all the bigger pictures my
whole family here I wanted to leave in
so if I can stay and make a difference
and an impact on the community make it
better my own neighborhood it's not sort
of perfect just to me it's a sense of my
family as well
you